that's the sad reality because even in
my country when I was growing up in
Lebanon remember Lebanon was the only
country to accept the third wave of
Palestinian refugees into the country in
1974-75 I was a 10-year-old little girl
my father owned a restaurant and we were
watching the images of the Palestinians
coming into Lebanon uh on our television
the first TV in town and I would hear
the conversations on the tables in the
restaurant you know people talking to
each other oh the bloody Jews look what
they're doing to the Palestinians
the general teaching not in my household
obviously because we are Christians but
the general teaching across the Arabic
world is Israel is Satan isra Israel
this has not changed it actually got
worse because in the Palestinian
territories they teach the children to
hate the Jews because the Jews have
horns the Jews are evil the Jews are
satanic and this is why you see the
barbarism happening but the barbarism is
not new and it's only not directed at
Israel only you know this is why people
think oh my gosh Hamas you know we need
to feel sorry for the poor Palestinians
people need to understand that
throughout the Middle East they have
zero tolerance for minorities and Israel
is the bullseye in their eye because
they could not kick Israelis
out I'm Dave ruin and joining me today
as an author a national security expert
and founder of act for America my friend
brijit Gabriel Bri welcome back to the
Reuben report hello my friend I'm
delighted to be back with you again I
I'm so glad to see you we don't see each
other enough I have to say before we
start that you accomplished something
that no other Ruben report guest has
ever done in all of the years of the
show you are the only guest who ever
brought tears to my eyes during a live
episode uh at we'll we'll uh link to the
clip down below but you were giving a
wonderful Soliloquy about America and
freedom and the importance of fighting
for freedom and you actually brought
tears to my eyes during the show and I
feel like that's something that uh that
has meaning that has meaning yes it does
you know why because you and I share the
same Soul we care about what happens in
the world we care about human suffering
it doesn't matter who are these humans
you know they could be Palestinians they
could be Muslims Christians Buddhists we
care about people but we hate evil we
stand up against evil and that's why
we're talking together well that's
exactly why I wanted to have you on the
show this week uh so I want to do a
little recap you you've told the story
many times you've written about it and
everything else but I thought we could
just do a few minutes on your childhood
growing up in Lebanon and sort of what
led you to being the person that you are
now we'll just recap that briefly and
then I want to talk to you about the
current events but your personal story
it's just so absolutely incredible and
so relevant to to everything that's
happening in the world right now exactly
especially as we watch what's happening
uh between Lebanon and Israel and Gaza
you know I was born and raised in
Lebanon uh Lebanon used to be the only
majority Christian country in the Middle
East most people don't know that we were
fair-minded we were open-minded we were
tolerant we were Multicultural we prided
ourselves in our multiculturalism we
welcomed everyone into our country
including Palestinians uh because we
wanted to share wisdom the
westernization which we had created in
the heart of the Middle East
unfortunately David we took people into
our country who did not share our values
my 911 happened to me in
1975 when actually Palestinian radical
islamist blew up my home bringing it
down burrying me under the rubble
wounded as they were trying to take over
our town I ended up in the hospital for
two and a half months and later ended up
living in a bomb shelter in an 8x10 room
bomb shelter without water without very
little food and no electricity and
that's where I lived for the next seven
years of my life robbed of my youth so I
understand I'm not only a terrorism
analyst who studied about terrorism in
college I'm an iwitness to Terror who
live to tell about it and that's why I
speak so forcefully and so p
passionately about standing up to those
who want to perpetrate evil if we could
people don't stand up and speak out who
else is going to do it yeah and as you
know my my friend Gad sad I'm sure you
know Gad his parents were actually
kidnapped by Palestinian terrorists in
Lebanon he he was Jew or he is Jewish
you're a Christian but the point is that
Beirut was once the Paris of the Middle
East uh and it certainly it certainly
isn't anymore and we'll see what happens
over the next couple weeks but can you
quickly just tell your journey then how
you got to America because there was
even a stop in Israel which people would
find interesting and then and then kind
of what out you here and then we'll get
to today's
issues well you know I I grew up in the
bomb shelter and uh Israel was our only
Lifeline I remember when we first went
into the bomb shelter uh people would
say you know my father would say you
know America's going to see all the
massacres happening in Lebanon and
America is going to come and France is
going to come and all these big
Christian nations are going to come and
we waited and we waited and nobody he
came and I remember 3 years into the War
I was around 13 years old and we got a
word that night that our town was going
to be shelled and uh you know a friend
of our of ours the Christian militia
fighter stopped by and he said I just
want you to know if I don't see you
tomorrow I wish you a merciful death
because I believe they're going to take
us over tonight and I remember David
dressing in my Sunday Best my Easter
dress uh because I want it to look
pretty when I am dead knowing that when
they come to slaughter me there would be
no one to bury me and I remember sobbing
begging my mother I don't want to die
I'm only 13 years old and there was
nothing my mother could say to me and I
remember sitting in the corner of our
bomb shelter and my father started
reading from Psalms I shall walk into
the valley of death and fear no evil for
thou art with me and my parents said to
me they said we lived a long life you
are an only child you are a young child
we will create a distraction when they
come to kill us and you just run towards
the Israeli border and don't look back
you see we live 2 and a half miles from
the Israeli border and we knew if we run
to the Jews and beg for help the Jews
are not going to slaughter us because we
had more shared values with them than we
had with the Muslims thank God I did not
have to make that decision that night
because that's the night when Israel
came in physically into Lebanon and
established the security Zone and set up
artillery bases around our town and
that's how we went on living for another
5 years until Israel invaded Lebanon
working with the Christians trying to
help the Christians take back their
country take back their democracy and
kick out the radical Islamic element
that had taken control of the country at
that time and that's how we came out of
the bomb shelter and back to rebuilding
Our Lives I ended up moving to Israel in
1984 and becoming news anchor for world
news in the Middle East based out of
Jerusalem covering world events and it
was there where I met my American work
correspondent American husband got
married and that's how I ended up coming
to the United States thinking I I left
everything behind my life story is
detailed in a New York Times bestseller
titled because they hate where I go into
far more details like when my mother was
wounded and we ended up in an Israeli
hospital and so many stories in the book
that would really move you and shed a
light about what's happening in the
Middle East right now so you can
understand how long how far back this
conflict goes all right so we're going
to we'll link to the book down below and
we're also going to link to our first
interview where we spent the hour really
telling your story because you just did
a very very obviously condensed version
of it but let's get to the to the issues
of the last two weeks or so I I take it
that even with the horrific barbarity
and the medieval like nature of all of
this that you probably of all people
were not particularly surprised I mean
did did even did the barbarity surprise
you I know the events probably didn't
surprise you what surprised me was the
attack itself that it was not stopped by
Israel that what that surprised the
world not just me Israelis are known for
their intelligence but the massacre
itself did not surprise me because I
understand how much they hate and that
that's why I titled my book because they
hate the massacre the the the Venom that
are being fed from their mother's milk
to hate the Jews Arab children from the
time they're born they teach their
children how much to hate the Jews and
that's a sad reality because even in my
country when I was growing up in Lebanon
remember Lebanon was the only country to
accept the third wave of Palestinian
refugees into the country in
1974-75 I was a 10-year-old little girl
my father owned a restaurant and we were
watching the images of the Palestinians
coming into Lebanon uh on our television
the first TV in town and I would hear
the conversations on the tables in the
restaurant you know people talking to
each other oh the bloody Jews look what
they're doing to the Palestinians the
general teaching not in my household
obviously because we are Christians but
the general teaching across the Arabic
world is Israel is Satan isra Isel this
has not changed it actually got worse
because in the Palestinian territories
they teach the children to hate the Jews
because the Jews have horns the Jews are
evil the Jews are satanic and this is
why you see the barbarism happening but
the barbarism is not new and it's only
not directed at Israel only you know
this is why people think oh my gosh
Hamas you know we need to feel sorry for
the poor Palestinians people need to
understand that throughout the Middle
East they have zero tolerance for
minorities and Israel is the bullseye in
their eye because they could not kick
Israelis out I mean look they tried to
eliminate the Armenians in Turkey the
same type of massacres that beheading
the killing the stabbing of a mother
pregnant getting the baby out stabbing
her in their stomach I mean we're
hearing the stories out of Gaza they did
the same thing to the Armenians in
turkey and the beginning of the century
the Israel didn't even exist 2 million
Armenians were massacred they did it to
the Christians in Lebanon they did it to
the yazidis in Iraq have we forgotten
what Isis did to the yazidis what Hamas
did to the Israelis is basically Isis
2.0 nothing has changed it's the same
tactics with the same barbarity that no
one in the Civilized World should accept
or stand for I can understand if people
want to fight for their rights you know
okay fine fight man to man take it to
the world stage go to the United Nations
make your case you don't go in and
kidnap six-month-old babies 5-year-old
babies 2-year-old grandbabies you're a
father I'm a mother we have children can
you imagine somebody taking our children
grandmothers who are on medications this
is barbaric behavior and it's
unacceptable why do you think so much of
the world seems unable or at least the
Western world seems unable to see this
with Clear Eyes is is it fear is it is
it stupidity is it confusion is it
propaganda it's propaganda it's
propaganda and we live in an age where
everybody does not want anybody to say
anything bad bad about them we live in
the age of feelings it's no longer about
logic everything is about feeling it's
not about whether something is good for
you or not or whether something makes
sense it's about how do you feel how
does this make you feel we live in a
world that's driven by feelings nowadays
and it is fueled by social media and so
nobody wants to see children suffering
but when you look at the Palestinians
sometimes they even fake the images of
the children who are suffering theyve
done that in the past we have seen them
do it this is not to minimize children's
suffering but we need to understand that
the perpetrators of evil continue to
perpetrate their evil and we cannot
stand for that but this is also aided
and abetted by the leftist Socialist
marxists in the west who do not want to
rock the belt and I have to tell you
especially in the leftist Jewish
Community I am not silenced by the
Muslims I am silenced when I speak by
the radical Lefty Jews who feel that if
I speak that way it could create
problems for them let's not rock the
boat I remember giving a speech at Duke
University in 2004 and in my speech it
was a pro pro-israeli speech on the eve
of the Palestinian solidarity movement
at Duke University and part of my speech
was obviously my speech was about
terrorism and I said the difference
between Israel and the Arabic world is a
difference between civilization and
barbarism a difference between democracy
and dictatorship a difference between
goodness and evil do you know that it
was the Jewish community that condemned
me and issued an apology to the
Palestinians for inviting me because I
offended the Palestinians if you Google
my name on social media every single bad
article written about me it's either the
ADL the anti-deformation league the
Southern Poverty Law Center the splc the
ACLU major Jewish organizations it's not
the Muslims it's not care so sometimes
it's the Jewish community who silences
those who are speaking up and calling
the barbarity because they think if we
are so inclusive and so tolerant and so
into diversity equity and inclusion
they're going to like us because they're
going to see how nice we are they don't
get the problem are you getting some
emails I'm getting an awful lot of
emails from Liberal Liberal or Lefty
Jews right now who are kind of like Dave
you know I I haven't really uh liked you
or listened to you over the last couple
years but now I'm kind of getting it are
you getting those too unfortunately not
yet but I hope to get that sometime I
I'll forward you a couple you can it
goes to you too you know it's sad but
but you know it's people like you and me
who are speaking out forcefully against
evil and look look how you were attacked
look how how I was attacked and yet we
continue to speak up because we do it
not for them because we do it because of
us who we are as people we will not sit
silent watching evil being perpetrated
and I think it is time for the community
for the Jewish Community as well as
anybody who's got a conscience in this
in this world to stand up and say enough
is enough and by the way where are the
Palestinian mothers condemning this
Behavior where are the Palestinian
daughters saying look we do not accept
the kidnapping of six-month-old children
or 2-year-old little girls or the rape
of teenage girls or the torture and rape
and a humiliation of grandmothers where
are the Palestinian voices speaking up
right now if you were you were in Israel
or you were an Israeli citizen or you
were advising Israel what what would you
be telling them to do right now because
it's not just the 1300 people that are
dead it's the 200 hostages it's the fact
that 7,000 Rockets have been shot since
this began and are still being shot at
this very moment what what would you
tell them to do in the face of what
you're
describing look war is ugly but the only
way you're going to fight a war is to
win it they have to win and yes in war
innocent people die die that's a part of
the collateral damage of war and I am
the last person in the world who
advocates for war I'm a Survivor of War
but I understand that if you are
fighting a disease like cancer you've
got to root cancer out because if you
don't cancer is going to kill you it's
not an if it's a it's a matter of when
it's not a question and right now in the
Middle East if we want to prosper in the
Middle East if you want to see a
prosperous and peaceful Lebanon a
prosperous and peaceful Palestinian
territories if prosper and peaceful
Jordan you have to take out evil
starting with Iran Iran is funding both
H and Hamas and they've got to take them
out have no mercy go out and take them
out do does it sort of seem to you like
a lot of the Arab countries they need
Israel in away like they kind of need it
because it's the scapegoat for all of
the bad things that they do to their own
citizens I mean in Lebanon as you
described Palestinians can't vote
there's I think 20 or 30 things they're
not allowed to be lawyers or doctors
there's like a series of things same in
Jordan like they sort of need Israel to
be like ah well we're doing some bad
stuff to you but now the Jews over
there well look the Arabs need the
Palestinians but at this point the Arabs
are prospering they are growing and the
Palestinians everywhere they go they
cause a problem that's the problem
that's why Egypt doesn't want them you
know I mean that's why they said no way
all they have to do is look at what the
Palestinians did in Jordan and what the
Palestinians did in Lebanon they
destroyed Lebanon King of Jordan
bulldozed 30,000 of them back in 1974 75
and kicked them out his own wife is a
Palestinian and he doesn't want to take
any more Palestinians they are a problem
anywhere they go and that's why they do
not want them but here's the other thing
look there are many Palestinians Living
in America there are many Palestinians
living in Australia there are many
Palestinians living all over the world
they have whatever right they want look
at Rashid ATL a member of Congress
elected in in the United States of
America you know why are they still
screaming about oh four generations ago
we used to have a home what about all
the Israelis that all the Jews that were
kicked out of Arab land over 1 million
Jews were kicked out of Egypt out of
Iran out of Lebanon out of Jordan out of
Syria they're not complaining we want to
go back they said okay we were kicked
out we'll start a new life somewhere
else just like I started the new life in
America you know we need to move forward
with the times and they need to get over
holding a grudge and moving over so
everybody can live in peace and by the
way uh Dave one important thing uh H AUD
Barack in 2000 offered them
97% of the territories
97% they did not want it they didn't
want it they wanted all of Israel
because they want to kick the Israelis
out and most people don't remember in
1964 when the PLO was founded the
Palestinian Liberation
Organization is Gaza was Egypt and the
West Bank was Jordan the PLO was was
founded to eradicate the Jews and anate
them and kick them into the sea a
Jordanian flag was flying over Gaza they
didn't call it occupied territories then
a a Egyptian flag was flying over Gaza
and a Jordanian flag was flying over the
West Bank how come they were not
screaming about occupation then what the
Palestinians want is basically to
eliminate the existence of Israel out of
the Middle East period I I'm so glad you
mentioned that because one of the things
I've really been trying to do for the
last two weeks is tell people basic
history and you know there's this whole
thing now where people are saying well
there's been an occupation for 75 years
and it's bizarre to me that people seem
to be calling for the British Empire to
return right I mean that's what in
essence you'd be asking for because
there never was a Palestinian State
that's right that's right there was
never a Palestinian State even Jews who
lived in that region were Palestinians
look Jerusalem was desolate land I mean
they didn't care of it have you seen
picture people need to Google pictures
of Jerusalem back a 100 years ago 150
years ago I mean it's it was nothing and
you know Israel Israel accepted whatever
the UN gave them and actually the reason
why Israel is on the coast with the sand
dunes that's what the UN gave Israel the
Arabs said okay fine give them that you
know they're going to die you can't grow
anything you know it's desolate land the
Jews turned the desert into an oasis
they turned it into Eden and then in
1967 the Arabs attacked the Jews that's
how you know Israel ended up uh with
Jerusalem this is how they ended up and
look at the Y kipur War Israel gained
more land every time the Arabs attacked
Israel and finally you know Israel
doesn't want the land they gave the land
to Gaza for those who are saying
occupation Israel withdrew out of Gaza
in 2005 and those of a lot of us did not
want Israel to withdraw out of Gaza
Israel dragged their own citizens out of
Gaza literally dragged them kicking and
screaming and you know because they
wanted to give all of Gaza to the
Palestinians here here it is it is yours
you build it they left all the green
houses the green houses you Gaza used to
export 50 million flowers a year just
flowers out of the Gaza Strip not to
mention tomatoes vegetables uh fruits uh
they used to export all over the world
the Israelis left all the green houses
behind I know in Israeli a Jewish
businessman in New York a very Lefty
Jewish businessman gave the Palestinians
$14 million so they could start with a
base money so they can continue running
the green houses so they can flourish
and grow their economy and hire people
and what did the Palestinians do in Gaza
within 24 hours they burned 126
synagogues destroyed the green houses
even dismantled the the pipes so they
stole the copper out of the pipes they
destroyed them these people shoot
themselves in the foot they could have
turned Gaza into Singapore but they
didn't it's not the fault of is is it's
the fault of Hamas and the Palestinians
do you think the West as a whole has the
the stomach or the fortitude or do we
even have enough sort of cultural energy
to to win this thing I don't I don't
mean the specifics of this war but what
seems to now be Brewing across all of
the globe where we're seeing these crazy
uh protests in London and in Paris and
in Sydney Australia etc etc do you think
the West has enough left to to fight for
all the good ideas that your life is an
example of yes the West will have the
resolve if they have a good leader look
under President Donald Trump you didn't
see anything happening like this across
the world zip for years nothing no Wars
you know why Putin feared him Russia
feared him Iran feared him China feared
him they didn't know what was what he
was going to do and when you have a
leader who is so strong he inspires
other leaders to be strong and so this
is how you see the creme rising to the
top and as soon as president Trump was
no longer at the White House the whole
world fell apart this is not a wasted
lesson on our enemies China Iran North
Korea uh um um Russia realize under
Biden they've got a four-year window of
opportunity and especially after the
withdraw that we did out of Afghanistan
and this is exactly why China sent their
ships surrounding Taiwan Russia invaded
Ukraine Iran now was proding and poking
at Israel they realized next now they've
got one year to do whatever they want to
do and this is why we must organize we
must come together and I urge people to
go to my website
actforamerica.org
actforamerica.org we are now 2 million
members mobilizing Nationwide we helped
pass 210 bills on the federal level and
the state level to protect the country
right now we have a petition on the
website to stop the importation of any
Palestinian refugee into America you
need to take action on that petition
right now because once the ground
Invasion starts in Gaza watch the
Democrats in our country start screaming
oh my gosh we've got to help the
Palestinian now is the time to speak up
and put pressure on your elected
officials so they can understand that
the American public is United we're not
going to import Palestinian terrorist
into our country go to actforamerica.org
right now sign that petition as well as
the action campaign we have to expel
Rashid from Congress all right we're
going to to that as well you're going to
set a record for the amount of links
that we're going to put in one show and
uh Bri I'm going to leave you with a
chance to make me cry again tell tell me
all about Freedom one more
time you and I are so passionate about
freedom because we understand what's at
stake I fight this war not because
somebody else is going to like me you
cannot believe the hate mail that I get
you cannot believe the death threats
that I get I like winess yeah yeah you
probably got something I
I do because I want to be able on my
deathbed to be able to look at my
children and tell them I did everything
I can to preserve freedom for you so you
can live in a great and prosperous
country this is what I want to leave for
my children freedom is only one
generation away from Extinction that's
why we need to fight for Freedom we need
to stand together and we need to fight
together this is a fight between
civilization and barbarism be this is a
fight between goodness and evil we need
to be on the side of good
rajid you never disappoint it was good
to see you thank you my friend have a
great day if you're looking for more
honest and thoughtful conversations
about politics instead of non-stop
screaming check out our politics
playlist and if you want to watch full
interviews on a variety of topics watch
our full episode playlist all right over
here and to get notified of all future
videos be sure to subscribe and click
the notification Bell